uh ya know so what do you what are you
you know how you got nothing
Spencer's drunk drunk it would know what
except II you won't love to drink Jesus
I feel attacked I do that I really I
only make drinks like in my house so you
don't have to drop by drinks when you're
out do you know what you're doing
yep of course you do I think I'm gonna
be a big asset here because I used to
bartend however it was at a country club
in the mill nowhere and I basically just
open beers for people I actually have
not had a drink since January so it's
been eight months he's gonna die
I think bloody mirrors are gross I
really like a meal and a beverage I like
those things separate I love Bloody Mary
I do love Virgin Mary's okay well this
is not that's gonna be like don't really
know how to respond to that I don't know
what the actual recipe is but I'm just
gonna kind of like we wing it okay do
you know what it's Bloody Mary oh yeah
it's tomato vodka celery celery salt
pepper Tabasco Jesus yeah
can we bring the vision are you stressed
out you don't think we need I just want
to have a beer
honestly cheers Cheers it's making
beverages and drinking yeah why not oh
wait
measure Perls measure you know what I'm
not gonna measure I'm just oh god it's
my whoa oh my god be careful I know
people like gonna splash in your face
good I love it
this is a competition stop don't look at
me that one makes me scared all right
tomato juice you're just gonna copy my
recipe you put your tomato juice in
first I am a big fan of vodka first
right making the mix tomato juice a
little lemon juice
you are hiding the lemon juice from me
is what you're saying could I see the
lemon and the lime juice actually also I
was just missing I'm getting triggered
by a white woman doing this and I don't
appreciate you looking at me and
spitting a spoon like that I hate it you
know it's fun when you don't measure I
feel like that's not this wife's it was
like whimsy yeah my secret weapon is
button
excuse you you think that'll help stop
it no I don't know that ketchup is
supposed to go have you ever had Bloody
Mary that you have ketchup in it
actually I've had a Bloody Mary I'm Tom
Cruise in cocktail the tomato juice why
are you dying what the hell you were a
bartender this should not be the
reaction you have to your own scream
yeah a little spicy it's really good
though
all right mine's about ready how you
doing over there hope this is a great
actor you can't tell me that doesn't
look like a great Bloody Mary oh you
have to drink that - yeah I do
great I've seen this in movies they like
they're not gonna work Wow it's like we
don't even know who's a - yeah right how
do they do it it's not big enough no no
that's it
I did it Merl
yep we did it we did it Bloody Mary's
y'all we're ready to taste them all
drinkers that's more fun Cheers who are
you dedicating this to Tom Cruise
[Music]
oh my godness actually this tastes
pretty good this is really good Chiz oh
yeah baby I don't even like Bloody Marys
and this is this is definitely my style
we did a stellar job I know honestly I
don't taste the vodka in this either I
do taste the ketchup Wow yeah this
tastes great
I'm very impressed with myself why I
refers with you to Oh mine's better you
like it don't you
oh you can taste the vodka you can I
don't really like to taste the liquor
hence all these I don't know what your
drink is but it lingers because now I
can only taste what is it yours
my face is heating up mm-hmm you need to
stop drinking both of you thanks Becky
yours definitely matches in color more
to what the recipe calls for dick yeah
that's fresh yeah not as aggressive with
the tomatoes oh yes I sell used to like
yours more it's similar to yours - the
spice this is gonna like hurt you this
just lightly chokes you like it's like a
fun hot way is that weird that make it
weird I made it weird now we're gonna
make some mai tais I am a traveler oh
yeah hi
I'm aria well I've no idea wasn't a mai
tai I feel like it's colored is the
color drink orange
I didn't don't think I ever had to make
in my time but uh I have no idea what
I'm doing I'm not gonna be lucky I'm
just gonna make my own thing over here
okay I don't remember if it's dark from
a light Rama I love to hear that so I'm
gonna do a nice base of the white room I
also I'm gonna do a nice base of the
white are just gonna follow me oh I
think it's dark rum god damn it is it
bull it's going on over here come on
is that vinegar don't look at mine don't
copy I think no idea what spend my time
well it is mostly rum and more rum all
that's in here right now is wrong yes
and I think that that means you are
making it right how many different kinds
of alcohol are you putting in that stop
I am definitely not copying you almond I
don't remember that being in my time but
I feel like why would it be here if it's
not in it smart yeah yeah you're
supposed to float it that's literally
I'm done I like the way you did that so
I am gonna copy your homework I'm
impressed
I thank you Matt I think mine looks fine
and I wasn't shooting for anything
better than fine if I'm gonna be frank I
think mine looks better yours looks a
little like Metamucil juice I don't link
from that is wrong that's not bad
it really isn't that bad I mean mine is
delicious that's not bad you're lying
right now sorry no seriously I think
that's bad Tyler oh no it's still in my
mouth every time I breathe in
yep that's wrong that actually isn't bad
I like mine better than yours if you put
your tongue in I did not need to see you
do it that way I hated watching Houston
people like that I'm gonna call this
tomorrow tomorrow let's get the real
drink in here okay that looks great
that looks like both of us combined yeah
I think maybe she use two different
kinds of rum you did that rum I used
didn't I use vodka I use the liquor
ketchup I use pepper oh wow this is
great this is really good usually you
drink my type with a straw so you're
gonna taste the rum but in general it is
pretty well made yeah that one allowed
past my teeth and it's smooth I don't
think I got me on the rum yeah that's
the way they're supposed to take you if
there are any bars out there that would
like to have this on your specialty list
I'm day we start this at a nice $33.99
we did this without a recipe and I'm
honestly very impressive I'm pretty
impressed I think my Bloody Mary was
pretty spectacular one two ten nine
point eight you named all the proper
ingredients and then didn't use them yes
I think it's a very fun skill to have
it's a it's a fun party trick and I love
someone who can make drinks in a party
YUM yeah cheers to a final midday drink
no we did pretty good
mm-hmm we should probably get lunch on
yeah we won't eat something who do you
want for lunch
ramen yeah we get Robin
[Music]